hey everyone here on the free Kirkham
channel in this tutorial I'm going to be
building a tool that every app and
startup should have I'm going to build a
dashboard to let you know if your app
Goes Down And if it does notify you over
email and SMS so in other words a clone
of the popular software as a service app
pages juicy my name is Anya Kubo and I'm
a course creator here on free co-camp as
well as on my own channel and I'm going
to be your guide to this wonderful
tutorial on building this platform here
today
one of the best ways to learn software
development is to create a slimmed down
version of software you use every day to
get a better understanding of how it
might work this process helps you
understand the problem space constraints
and techniques required to build a
real-world use case pager Duty is
awesome as it helps alert teams to high
priority incidents like web outages or
security issues using pre-configured
configuration strategies and
multi-channel notifications in this
tutorial we will recreate some of the
key components of this application using
JavaScript for application logic
postgres store our data resource to
build our user interface and back-end
workflows and finally twilio to power
SMS notification as well as SMTP by the
end of this tutorial you will be able to
create data structures and postgres to
feed into your application
this would include creating an incidents
table as well as team members table we
will then feed this data into our UI so
we can see it and interact with it so as
you will see here under the incidents
Tab and the team members tab that we are
bringing back all that data
the team members tab will also help us
see who is working on what as well as
their shift times so that we can tell
who is on call and when we will also
then be able to see all the incidents
that are currently acknowledged and
being worked on as well as filter them
down to just the ones assigned to a
specific user we will add functionality
to bring up data if we click on specific
rows and much more we will also add the
ability to add team members from the
interface as well as add a new incidents
via the interface as well as delete a
team member or delete an interface so a
bunch of stuff going on here
and finally we will hook up twilio and
SMTP so that we can send email
notifications and SMS notifications to
our team members in case the website
theoretically goes down
this video is created thanks to a grant
from Riesel the local solution for
building internal tools and platforms so
what are we waiting for let's do it
okay so let's do it first off I'm just
going to create a new app so I'm just
going to go ahead and click on here and
I'm going to call this page of Judy
clone okay and click create the app
so there we go we've just created our
app essentially this is essentially our
work Zone and I'm going to start off by
just dragging in some UI in order to
make it look like a pager 2D clone so
the first thing I'm going to do is
actually just drag in some tapped
containers as we're going to have two
tabs here one to view the incidents I
want to view all our team members so
let's make that reflect here we can also
rename this actual UI component so I can
call it main tabs if I wish
okay great and now here I'm just going
to change this to say incidence
and this one to say team members so we
are literally just creating our tabbed
container just like so
we can of course also change the colors
of this so if you just highlight the
whole UI component and then go down here
I can choose the header background color
I can choose the footer background color
or I could just choose the background
I'm going to go ahead with canvas to
make it match the background that we
have
okay and if we wanted a little darker we
can also choose our own custom color so
for example I could do Hex
e-e-e-e-e or just three E's for short
and that will also be applied
wonderful to get rid of the third view
that we are not going to be using simply
just go ahead and click on here and
delete it from View
so there we have it one View and a
second View
we can also personalize the actual
selected colors so I'm going to go with
green for now as I think it looks better
okay
wonderful now under incidents what do we
want to show well we should probably
have some kind of header right so let's
go ahead and select a text option we can
have simple text or we can have a text
area a rich text editor or even editable
text I'm just going to go ahead and
select the text option and we can even
choose if we would like to use HTML
elements to kind of decide how big each
of the text elements are going to be so
I can have incidents on all teams as a
title just like so and it's styled like
an H1 element title if you wanted to
give a custom siding to this H1 element
that is also possible okay
all you would have to do is go to
scripts and styles and add in some
custom CSS for this whole document we
are not going to be doing that now but I
just thought it was worth giving you a
sneak peek at that
next up what do I want well we can have
dividers to kind of separate out
everything in here
so I'm going to in fact use a divider to
separate the title from the table that
we are going to input
now let's put in a table
so our table at the moment is not going
to mean much
okay it's just gonna have some dummy
data in there so there is some dummy
data that's being fed in we're going to
delete all of this as we're going to use
some actual data from a postgres
database that we are going to make so
just leave that blank for now in the
meantime I'm also just going to drag in
some text to go below here
and I'm going to use the H5 element this
time so a smaller header
to say your open incidents
and then just drag in some more text so
that we can actually see those incidents
for now I'm going to put zero triggered
and make this red
so the text is going to be danger and
then just copy and paste that and this
time this is going to be to show our
acknowledged
incidents
and I'm going to change this color to be
info
okay
wonderful so there's a lot you can do
with styling with this text I'm going to
leave it like that for now and we're
going to change this number dynamically
based off our you guessed it our
database so in fact I'm just going to
copy this and paste it because we're
going to drag this over to the right and
see all our open incidents as well so
we've got your open incidents let's also
have all open incidents and again we're
going to feed that number in dynamically
on component text 7 and component text
file
great
now I'm going to add a button this
button once clicked is going to help us
add a new incident to our database so we
can actually do that from our UI which
is kind of cool
and this button we can style it up so I
can have ADD incident if I wish and and
let's make this blue
green just to match the rest of this
board and I couldn't even choose to make
it a little bit bigger
next I'm just going to use a container
to contain a bunch of stuff that I want
to add next so I'm just going to put
that in here like so for now and this
time in fact I'm going to get rid of the
header so we can do that we can select
the whole UI component and then I can
choose to hide the header so at the
moment we're just showing the body if
you wanted to show footer then you can
do that that is totally up to you
okay
wonderful so we have one container I'm
actually going to have two so I'm just
going to drag in another one right below
here
okay so there we go this one again I
don't want to have a header showing so
I'm just going to hide it
now in the first one we're going to just
display who is on call so I'm going to
just have the title here of on call okay
and I'm just going to make it green so
I'm going to change the color to be
green up the text we can also make it
bold if we wish okay so I'm just going
to use a opening and a closing tag for
that to make that fold
the next thing I'm going to drag in is a
place to actually display whoever is
currently on call so for now I'm just
going to put XXX as we don't really know
who's on call yet because once again
we're going to get that from our
database so I'm just going to also make
sure that's in an H3 element
just like that just to make sure it's a
bit Bolder and we can even use an avatar
so I can just drag in a pre-made
component that's right that will show us
our Avatar
at the moment again this is just based
off my information my user detail I'm
the current user of this app but we will
override this so in fact just so I don't
forget to do this I'm just going to put
XXX
for all of these so that we don't forget
to add that in dynamically
great now we can put a divider or we can
add a footer it's totally up to you
let's choose to add a footer and in the
footer here I'm going to add some more
information I'm going to drag in a text
component just like so and here I'm
going to put in bold you are on call 4
and once again this is going to be fed
dynamically I'm going to essentially
create a list of tags so we can find
these tags in here too and I'm just
going to put them in below just like
so okay so that's going to display what
we as the person on call are Uncle full
in here again I'm just going to drag in
some more texts this is going to say in
bold
on call now
let's go ahead and make this color green
and here we're just going to list out
all the incidents that we are currently
on quote for
okay so I'm going to just put XXX for
now as that will be fed dynamically and
we're also going to show the shift of
the current person that is on call so
it's really obvious
I'm gonna put once again and fold
your shift
and then close this tag
and then actually display the two shift
times as well as some contact
information so this is going to be from
and we're going to put our starting time
of the shift and this is going to be 2
and we're going to put the end time of
the shift of the current person on call
and here I'm just going to put some
information like contact
and then I'm going to put
info at
pre-codecamp.org as well pretending this
is free code counts pager Duty app to
make any changes to your shift
okay
wonderful so that's really
it
okay so that's for showing all the
incidents of course we haven't hooked
this up to any data quite yet let's work
on the team members tab next
so just like with the team members tab
in fact what I'm going to do is so super
simple I'm just going to copy this I'm
going to copy the divider I'm going to
copy the button and I'm also going to
copy this container
and click command C and inside here I'm
just going to paste it in okay so it
looks kind of similar however we're
going to change this title to say team
members
okay and on the add incident button well
I'm going to put add new team member of
course as this is dealing with team
members and in here well let's just
delete that we don't really want that
I'm just going to show the selected team
member from the table that we're going
to have we're not going to have an
avatar so let's delete that we're not
going to have Ur on chord four instead
we're going to have assigned operations
so we can see the assigned operations
that are there for the user okay so
there we go we have the sign operations
that will be viewed as a tag list and
I'm also going to put in the shift dates
for the user we are selecting
okay so once again in bold I'm just
going to put shift dates
and close that
okay and once again let's just put from
to
and then I'm also going to put the eval
of the person that we want to contact
okay so our email is gonna go there
great
now once small is auto drag in a table
as this is going to show all our team
members from what you guessed it or
postgres database so let's go ahead and
delete all that data that is some fake
data that is being passed through
and finally outside of the incidents and
outside of the members so outside of
this whole tabbed container I'm gonna
have another container okay so I'm going
to put in a container in fact let's make
a form as essentially we are going to be
sending something from here we're going
to be sending an email okay
so there we go there is an email form
for us and I'm just going to put email
poser as that is what I want to build
let's make the title of this so the
header I'm going to change the color of
the header so if we finally had a
background I'm just going to go with
highlight as the color of choice and
let's change the submit button too I'm
going to make a warning okay
and in here I'm going to put send two
and then whoever we are highlighting
from the team members is going to be the
person to receive this email so that is
going to be quite cool and another thing
we can do is use the Rich Text Editor so
now we get a whole Rich Text Editor
component this is pretty cool okay
imagine trying to curve that out
yourself and in here we're going to put
hi and we're just going to put the
selected user from our table
so that's it that's what we have built
so far now let's get to linking all of
this up
so for this tutorial I'm going to use
render.com render.com is essentially a
way for us to host our database in a
non-paid way okay so please go ahead and
just go to the dashboard sign up go to
the dashboard and we are going to sign
in I'm going to just choose to sign in
with Google okay so please choose your
own way of signing in it's up to you and
once here I just want you to click on
new and it's a postgres database that we
are going to create that is hosted on
render I'm going to call this pager Duty
as that's what I'm creating this
database for I'm happy for the database
to be randomly generated as well as the
username and we're just going to select
the free tier and click create database
okay so it really was that easy that is
creating in the meantime I'm going to go
here and go to resources
so let's go ahead and create a new
resource this is going to be a postgres
SQL database I'm just going to call it
pager Duty as that will be easy for us
to find the host
well that is this so I'm just going to
copy this host name like so but then I'm
also going to
have to append
dot Oregon
postgres.render.com so just make sure to
append that keep the port as 5432 as you
see here the database name is pager Duty
so let's put that in here and as
authentication we're going to use the
database username which is this
and the database password so here is the
password please go ahead and use your
own because this one will not work after
this tutorial as
so there we go I'm going to click
Connect using SSL and let's just test
this works and connection is a success
this is because we left the address
IP address as everywhere okay but if you
wanted to you know keep it kind of
private you might consider adding these
IP addresses so great let's create our
resource
let's go back to the resources and now
I'm just going to shut that down and
refresh this so it loads the latest
resources and I'm going to choose
pagerduty as my resource name that's
just the one I made
okay so I'm actually going to use this
UI in order to add the actual tables
that I'm going to use for this project
okay so I'm going to just go ahead and
create my first table so I'm going to
use the create table command and I'm
going to create a table of incidents
okay so get up your parenthesis and
let's define what's going to go on our
table well I'm going to put in my ID
which is going to take an integer value
I'm going to put an urgency level which
is just going to take bar chart 30.
so 30 characters essentially I'm going
to have triggered is this a triggered
event
well it's yes or no so I'm going to have
a Boolean for this
next I'm also going to have acknowledged
this will also be a Boolean
as well as resolved which is also going
to be a Boolean next we're going to have
a description of the actual incident
itself so that's going to take bar chart
and I'm going to actually limit that to
30. okay we don't want them to be too
long and then assigned to and this is
going to take an integer in fact it's
going to take the ID of an employee and
I'm also going to have a created
date which is going to take a date so
that's what my table looks like don't
forget to finish it off with some
semicolons let's check if this works I'm
going to click save and run
and great that seems to have worked we
haven't got any errors I'm going to call
this playground for now as I'm
essentially using this as a little mini
playground to add our tables
okay so that was one thing that we have
done you can keep this in here if you
wish in fact I'm just going to comment
that out because I'm going to create a
new table so create
table team this is going to take our
team so what's our team going to be made
up of well each team member is going to
have an ID which I'm going to say has to
be an integer they're going to have a
first name which I'm going to take as
virtuous or characters let's just do 30
again eight last name which I'm going to
be super strict about this too of course
you don't have to have 30 I'm just
choosing two for now and then email uh
varchar fine let's put 225y dot okay you
can have higher character numbers if you
wish
next I'm going to have a phone number of
your teammate which is going to be an
integer value an avatar which is
actually going to be a URL to an image
on the internet
and then we're going to have on call to
check if they're on court or not and
this is going to be a Boolean value as
well as a shift
start and that's going to be a date
a shift end value which is also going to
be a date and incidents that they are
working on which is going to be text but
it's also going to be an array of text
so that's how I would write that great
and just finish off some semicolons and
hit save and run
so there we go we have just added our
table for team members so I'm just going
to comment that out I'm going to go
ahead and just add two incidents just to
start off with just so we have stuff to
play around with so I'm going to insert
into the table called incidents
and we're going to insert an ID an
urgency value a triggered value
an act knowledge value
resolved value a description assigned
to
making sure to spell it exactly the same
as we did up here
created date and that should be it so
those are the values we want to insert
into let's actually get the values so
the value for the ID I'm going to put
incident ID number one we're going to
put urgency as the string of high as
well as the triggered is going to be
true that knowledge is going to be true
and resolved is going to be false so
we've put in Boolean values for those
and now I'm just going to put in a
description of this incident it's going
to be devops escalation
so just like that it's going to be
assigned to the employee with id201 and
then we're just going to put in a date
that this was created at I'm going to
put a date in the past okay because you
know we don't want to put everything as
today's date so there we go okay and
don't forget to finish that off with a
semicolon okay so there is our semicolon
and just hit save and run
great and that has run successfully
so that is one incident let's just add
another one this one is going to have
the value of 2. let's put the
urgency as low let's have true maybe
false false this time for triggered
acknowledged and resolved this one can
be called security Ops
escalation making sure to spell security
correctly it's going to be assigned to
user 201 as well and let's put this as
maybe one day
earlier and click save and run
great and I'm just going to comment that
out I am now just going to insert
into
team so I'm only going to insert one
person into here I think that will be
fine
we need to get the ID we need to also
get the first name of the person we are
inserting and the last name making sure
to spell exactly the same as we have in
this table next up is email
next up is the phone number
next up is the avatar
then I'm gonna have on call
let's have shift
starts
shift and
and the incidents attached to them once
again just making sure that everything
is spelled correctly because next we're
going to put in the values and the value
of this well this is going to be team
number 201 the name is going to be Anya
and their last name is going to be Kubo
now my email address I'm just going to
put as the string of Anya at
freecodecamp.org
the phone number I'm just going to put a
fake phone number for now
and as my avatar well I'm just going to
use my avatar from free code Camp so
please make sure to take an image that
you know is unlikely to be taken offline
or alternatively store them yourself on
imager.com or you can put them on an
external database such as AWS for
example
so I'm just going to copy this image
address and I'm just going to paste it
in like so
now after the Avatar I'm just going to
specify if this person is on call I'm
going to put true and then I'm going to
also
put it a made-up start shift time a
made-up and shift time as a string
and then an array so we can literally
just put the words array like so and
then I'm going to
put in devops escalation
and security
Ops escalation
as the incident assigned to this user
okay don't forget to end it with some
semicolons hit save and run uh it is
saying integer out of range that's fine
I'll just change the format of the
folder
and now I'm going to add in that twilio
phone number making sure to add zero
zero one at the front and hit run and
Save
now it does say that integer out of
range which is kind of strange I don't
think this should be out of range but
that is fine we might have to make this
a string instead so let's go ahead and
make that a string I'm actually going to
just comment this out we're going to
drop the table drop table team so
essentially we're going to delete it
because we have to change the data type
of the phone number
so make sure to drop that and now I can
create the table again so this is good
for anyone who perhaps made an error in
the first place and I'm just going to
change this to varcha as well so that
will now take a string so save that and
run it to create this table again with
the number being an email
and now we can insert into team after
you have commented this out so save and
run
and great we have now added our first
team member so I'm just going to comment
this out for now
okay so that was our playground and now
I'm gonna get some data that we can feed
in into our first table of all the
incidents so let's create a new resource
and let's make sure that the research is
pager Duty I'm just going to do select
all from the table incidents and click
save and run let's see what that looks
like and indeed we get two incidents
back I'm going to rename this get
incidents as that is essentially what
this query does and now in here instead
of adding data manually I can get
incidents and get the data of those
incidents so that it feeds in there and
it's automatically mapped out to these
lovely table rows what is cool is if you
want to see the whole data object that
comes back you can all you have to do is
go to State and get the incidents and
there's the data and you will see all
that information as arrays that we can
use okay so that's just in this tab on
the left here I'm just going to minimize
that left panel now
so that's what I have done let's carry
on working on this
so another cool thing we can do is
actually adjust which kind of columns we
want to see or edit or anything like
that so for example I can choose to
hide the description if I want so I'm
just going to select the whole table and
I'm going to choose to hide the
description by pressing on this little I
right here I'm also going to hide the
assigned to I'm going to keep the
created date and I can even if I want
add a new column add a custom column and
this column is going to help me delete
incidents if I want so at the moment I'm
not really going to put anything in here
apart from just decide that it's going
to be a button okay that is my button
and the value of this is just going to
say delete
so there we go we can of course make the
columns smaller if we wish and just in
general play around with this a little
bit better
so I'm happy with this table let's now
change the value of this hard-coded zero
and I can do so easily I can literally
get the incidence data and I can look
inside to see how many of the objects
triggered are true right so for this I'm
going to use the filter method and I'm
going to look through each item okay by
essentially filtering through each one
I've used I as the representation of
each item that we are filtering and if I
equals true I'm going to get the length
of that array so as you will see here
two incidents are triggered and if we
look here indeed two incidents are
triggered so if we do the same for
acknowledge we should get one
acknowledged incident so let's try again
I'm going to use the two Kylie braces as
that is how we do things in retool in
order to get values from the queries so
the query we wrote is called get
incidents right so I'm essentially
getting the name of whatever we called
this query and getting the data from it
and I am going to this time filter by
the acknowledged so I'm going to get
acknowledge and use the filter method on
it to essentially filter and if I or
each item in that array equals true I'm
going to get the whole arrays length and
indeed we get A1 so once again Kylie
braces in order to access data from the
queries the query I I wanted to access
is the get incidence query you can see
all the information that comes back here
and again if you really want to see the
whole object we can look in here so I've
got incidents I've got into the data
object then I've gone into the
acknowledge array and I filtered out
anything that is equal to true and got
the length of that array
got it
cool
okay so to do your open incidents we're
going to have to do something else
because we're going to actually have to
get the user okay so perhaps let's do
that next now who was the user well I
think the user should be whoever's on
call right so let's go ahead and create
a new resource query I'm going to call
this get user and I'm going to select
all from Team this time so the table of
Team where on call equals true I'm going
to save and run this so there we go it
comes back with one user and at all
points we really should only have one
person on call right so that is a kind
of rule that should be done in the back
end this isn't a front-end thing so we
can just assume that this will come back
with one user at all times
so that is going to be our user and I'm
going to filter incidents by the user so
let's write another resource I'm going
to write filter incidence
and I'm going to select all from
incidents
where
assigns
to
equals and then I'm just going to get
the user
data so this is our get user query we're
going to get the ID we're only going to
get the first ID from the array because
we are assuming there is only one so
that should be fine and don't forget
your semicolons at the end so I'm just
going to save and run that and making
sure to spell incidents there correctly
let's just run that again
okay so two items come back this is
because indeed two items are assigned to
me and your Cuba because my user ID is
201
great once we get to adding more
incidents in here you will see how that
changes
so now that means I can use my filter
incidence query to dynamically update
these so once again use our Kylie braces
filter incidents is the query I want to
use I want to get the data from it
and I want to get the triggered
array
and I want to filter it based on advice
if the item in here in this array equals
true and I want to get its length okay
so two will be triggered that is correct
because I'm just going on my open
incidents and at the moment I'm the only
user in here so once again you guessed
it we're going to get the cardi braces
we're going to get the filtered
incidents so let's get the filter
incidents data and this time we're going
to get the acknowledge array and filter
it by looping over I and if I equals
true we're going to get the length of
this array at the end
wonderful
so this is all looking good
we can now actually also fill out this
because we are technically getting the
user so we can use this query let's run
it again let's see what it looks like to
find out who's on call right
so I can use my curly braces to go into
the get user query and get the data and
get the first name that comes back to us
okay so I'm going to get the first name
and I could also put the second name
I've literally just put a space there
this will work I'm going to get user
data
last
name
great and same for the Avatar well I'm
gonna get user data
Avatar at this time and just go into the
first item of that array
same for the email so on the label here
I'm just going to go into get user data
get the email
and get the first item from the array
in fact maybe we should have that on the
actual caption of the label and here we
will just have the first name again
so I'm just going to take all of this
and whack it onto the label here
we can also essentially map out what the
tags are and here we're going to get the
incidents right so let's get rid of that
Curly braces get user data incidents
and we're gonna have to go into the
first item that array and there we go so
these incidents have now been mapped out
onto here
great let's also do the same for here so
I'm just going to
show all the incidents I'm going to get
the user data incidents
and actually if I treat this as an
element we can actually just put the
array in here like so okay so that's
something I have done
now from here I'm just going to get into
the user again data and get the
shift start
and once again on here I'm going to get
user data this time shift end
great so we've populated all of that
based off the get user query how cool is
that next up let's work on adding an
incident so for this I'm actually going
to create a model that's going to pop up
so in fact let's go ahead and just put
that up here and I'm just going to
delete this button so delete it and I'm
going to change the text of this to be
add incident
let's also change it to be green so
I'm just going to minimize that for now
as well as the state the accent
background is going to be green I'm just
going to make it a little bit bigger
okay so that is our modal
in here I'm just going to put in some
text so I'm going to drag in some text
and this is going to say add incident
I'm going to make this an H2 element add
incident just like so
let's also put a divider
just going to put that in right down
here
and then I'm going to create a number
input so one specifically to put in
numbers
so just like that with the label being
incident ID
great next I'm going to create a drop
down so I'm going to have this select
drop down just like so and I'm going to
put the value of the label as urgency
and I'm going to hard code my options
option one is going to be high option
two is going to be medium
and option three is of course going to
be low so those are my options
and if you leave the label as empty it
will just take the value as the default
and I'm happy with that
next I'm just going to create some
switches so this is because I'm going to
be dealing with Boolean values so I'm
fine with this I'm going to have one for
triggered
please
also have one for acknowledged
and finally let's have one for resolved
okay so those are my three options right
there
you can of course start them up as much
as you want
next we're going to have a description
input so for this I think we should just
have some text so I'm going to put in a
text input this is why I kept the
description short Max 30 characters
because you know that's not a lot to
work with and we can also cap this as
well so we can cap the value
we can have a max length of 30 just like
so and let's go ahead and put
description
here
and finally let's have one more select
drop down so select
and here we're going to select who this
is assigned to so I'm going to put
assigned to
and instead of having options I'm going
to map out the options this time the
data source for this well we're going to
have to get all the team members right
so let's go ahead and write a new query
I'm going to call this get team as we're
going to get all the team members and
the query for this is Select
all from Tim and run it so that's going
to be the data source get team and
that's going to Auto populate for you
and great this is fantastic is exactly
what I want
okay so now we can actually choose which
team member to select in such a nice way
okay and whichever one we select it's
actually going to pick out the ID of
that item so if I select me the value of
this one is selected will be 201 so
readable and then practical
great and finally I'm just going to put
in a Watson
that's going to submit this modal
so I'm just going to put submit and we
can actually make the height of this
modal Dynamic based on what's inside so
I can do hug content and then that will
happen
okay wonderful now let's write a query
for adding
an incident to add incident just like so
making sure the resource is pager Duty
and once again we're essentially going
to use this piece of code so I'm just
going to copy all of that because that
is the code that we all need in order to
add a new incident of course when it's
uncommented out
so that's what we are going to insert
into the table incidents however this
time the values will not be hard coded
they will in fact be taken from here so
I'm going to use my Kylie breezes to
access this component which is called
number input 1 number input one and get
its value if you hover over that you
will see that's a zero where if I change
this that will change and you will see
the value is now two so it's literally
getting the value of that input this
second one is the urgency right and this
component is called select one so I'm
going to regret select one and get its
value once more so if I choose high that
will now be hi
wonderful
so hopefully that's kind of making sense
next we're going to go on these switches
so that is going to be switch one two
and three so once again I'm just going
to use my Kylie braces to get switch
one's value switch two is value as long
as these are of course in the correct
order and then switch three's values to
switch
three value and finally I'm just going
to minimize this we need to get the
description which is text input one and
these select two value
so description is going to go here and
that is text
input value one I believe yes text input
one and select two
so select to value and we're just going
to get today's date so I'm going to use
the new date object from JavaScript to
do that
once again make sure it's in Kali braces
and just call it so that's what I've
done I'm essentially getting the values
of all these inputs let's have a go at
filling this out so let's go incident
number three agency High triggered
acknowledge not resolved description
well I can go ahead and put anything I
want let's put
deployment
and assigned to well I'm the only one
here right now so great and now this
button well we need to trigger the ad
incident query we just wrote so I'm
going to add an event listener control
query that's been generated for me at
incidents because I'm currently on that
query and we're going to trigger that
okay that looks great to me so now
if I submit this I'm going to run this
query with all these values filled out
so you will see the values that we are
essentially going to put they've all
been now filled out
and if this works well on success I
actually want to do a few things right I
want to get all the incidents again so
the freshest incidents and I also want
the model to close so I'm going to
control a component of this time and
that component is the modal so let's go
ahead and find it and I want it to close
we can also add some other fun things
like confetti if we want so confetti
let's go ahead and do that and save so I
haven't run this because I want to
trigger it by pressing this button so
I'm going to click on here
uh we have got an error let's debug
uh it would seem I just put a extra
string I didn't delete those strings
properly so now let's save let's try
again and hit submit
and great that has worked and ta-da we
have gotten the fresh incidents again
and that has updated our table so this
is looking great and you will see that
this has been updated to two
oh this has not been updated that's
because we of course also need to run
the filter incidents method as well so
on success of adding an incident let's
add the get
filtered incidents
okay so there we go now I've just run
that again so we would have added the
same stuff again because as you will see
that information is still there
so now let's work on deleting that third
one okay because we don't want it but at
least we know this is working and this
is working and everything is updating so
now let's work on deleting an incident
so this one I'm going to call delete
incident
the resource is going to be pager Duty
and all I'm going to do is delete from
incidents where ID equals
and then this is table one
selected
row
data ID so this for the eagle eyed is
going to cause a problem this is because
you know if we essentially delete this
one it's going to look at the ID and
it's going to delete both of these so
just keep in mind that whenever you add
an incident that ID needs to be unique
so save that and on success of this well
once again I'm going to essentially get
all the incidents
and run the filter incidents
query once more so let's save that and
now let's hook up this button to that so
let's find that custom button that we
made and on click we're going to run a
query and that query is delete incident
okay so that's what we want to happen
now let's try it out I'm going to click
delete incidents
and that should delete and it's deleted
all of these incidents and it's gotten
all the incidents again so we can view
them in the table and it's updated these
based on the filter incident
query and the get incident query
wonderful
so I'm really happy with this let's
carry on
okay now it's time to move on to the
team members page
so in here let's go ahead and use the
get team query in order to populate this
table so once again I would use my curly
braces get the get team query and the
data from it and that should
automatically update my table right here
again we can choose which columns to
hide so I'm going to hide the Avatar
column this time I'm going to hide the
phone number I'm also going to hide the
start shift and the end shift
as well as the incidents okay and I'm
going to add a custom column once again
to be able to delete that user so this
is going to be a button so let's go
ahead and do that
so there we go there is a button that
says delete after we update the value
so great before we go deleting anything
let's populate this container with this
selected user as well as add
functionality to add a new team member
so to do this I'm actually going to
rename this component as I mentioned
this is something you can do so I'm just
going to call it team table
okay and that just makes it more
reasonable for when I use this table
so the team table so I can literally use
my cardi braces to access the team table
component
and get the selected row data and I
could just grab the first name if I wish
of that selected row and of course I
could do so for the last name too so
once again let's get up our cardi braces
and I'm just going to use 10 table
selected route data last name this time
and wonderful
great we can also use the Avatar that I
have hidden from the table but it still
does exist so if I want to just go ahead
and grab an image
just like so
and now I can go into the team table
once more selection of data and get the
Avatar as that exists
on here even though it's a deleted
column once again if you want to have a
look at the objects for this just have a
look in here look at get team data and
we're getting the selected row data
right Avatar
and that is the URL that I am getting
great and now let's populate these other
components
so here once again I would delete all
that I would use the team table selected
wrote data to get the array of incidents
that will be mapped out onto these tags
and you know what to do this should be
easy now once again let's go into the
team table selected data and get the
shift start time and then also get the
shift end time
so team table selected data
shift and is what I want and here I'm
just going to display the email address
so once again team table selective.data
dot email
wonderful and that was it very painless
now let's get to adding a new team
member so for this I'm actually going to
use the modal components I'm just going
to put that in here for now and let's
delete this button
so I'm just going to delete that and
move this over so move over the modal
button
just to here it's going to make it a
little bit bigger and of course we can
style it up I'm just going to make
everything green and then let's change
the font of this to be add new team
member
great
so now let's work on the module
so for this I'm just going to drag in
some text let's make this an H3 element
and it's going to say add a new team
number
just like that and I'm just going to
drag it out I'm also going to have
another divider just like we did
previously so I can put that divider in
right here
and then let's add some inputs so I'm
going to put a number input
and this is going to say team member ID
so let's change the text on the label to
say team member ID
let's also just have a text input this
is going to be for the first name and
we're going to also have one for the
last name too so let's change this to
say first name
and I'm actually going to copy and paste
so the second one shows up so I can
change this to last name we're also
going to have email so there is a
special email input we can use
so there we go I'm just going to drag
that in like so and put it here
maybe let's put some two dots there just
so we can make it look the same and then
we're going to have a phone number well
this is actually a text input as we know
because we changed that to be a text
input
so I'm just going to put phone number
like
that
and let's also have an avatar image but
this is just going to be a URL to
something on the internet as we
mentioned for now of course you don't
have to have it like that you can link
this up to an AWS database if you wish
in order to store images next we need to
have a check box to allow us to check if
someone's on call or not
okay so let's go ahead and put on call
here and then someone can choose to
select that or not select that that'll
be up to them we also have a date picker
so I'm going to go ahead and just put in
this date picker right here
and by default that will show you
today's date which you can then change
and I'm going to go ahead and change
this label to start date
and let's make an End date one two so
end date end Date Update shift
and finally we're also going to have a
select but in multiple select okay
because we can pick multiple
operations assigned to one user so I'm
just going to change this to operations
and let's hardcore the options the first
one is going to be email Ops
escalation
just like that the second one is going
to be security Ops
escalation
and the third one is going to be devops
escalations input devops escalation
just like that okay so now people can
select multiple ones which is quite cool
and then finally let's have a submit
button so I'm just going to get rid of
that and find a button so that people
can submit these answers
so there we go and let's change this to
say Summit
so wonderful I think that is looking
good now let's get to writing our query
for this
so this is going to be add team member
so let's change this to add team member
just make sure that's to the correct
resource and then we are also going to
insert into so this is where our
playground comes in handy we're going to
insert into team it's going to grab all
of that
add team member and just paste it in
uncomment it out and just change the
values so the value of this will be
whatever the number input 2 is so let's
grab number input to Value this will be
text input to Value so just get rid of
that and put text input to value and
then we have text input 3 value
so text input three value
we'll also have email one so get rid of
that string and put email one value
we also then have the phone number which
is text input four so let's go ahead and
put text input for Value then we have
the Avatar right
which would be text input five value so
let's get rid of that text input file
value and then we have a check box so
the check box is check box one and then
we have date one date two and
multi-select one so that should be easy
to remember check box value one this
will be date one
so date one value this will be date two
value
and this will be the multi select option
so multi
select one value
great so now let's save this I'm
actually going to also add some things
to do on success because on success we
want to essentially re-get the team
right so that will happen on success and
then let's also have some confetti
because why not let's also close the
modal so we're going to this time
control a component and find the second
modal that we made
so just scroll down for modal two and
then we want to close it okay so that's
what we want to do on success
so now I'm going to save that and hook
up the submit button to run that query
so let's just add an event handler
control query add team member so
wonderful let's try it out I'm going to
put employee 202 I'm going to put bow
cards
and as an email I'm just going to put a
bow at free
codecamp.org and as a phone number I'm
just going to make this one up
okay just like that
and as an avatar image I'm just going to
get one off the internet logbook
okay so I'm gonna copy the image address
and just paste that in he's not going to
be on call and let's put his start date
as the 11th and the end date as the 14th
and the operations he's going to be
assigned to
well let's have a look
I think there's just an email Ops and
security devops as well so now let's hit
submit
and great though has been added this is
looking wonderful
and finally let's add a way to actually
delete a team member so all I'm going to
actually do
is write a new query so let's add a new
query resource query this is going to be
delete
team
member
make sure the resource is correct and
we're going to delete from
team
where the ID equals the team table
selected row data ID right because we're
here if we're selecting this one and we
want to delete it we just want to make
sure that it's the correct
ID and that's how we're going to delete
that team member so on success we're of
course gonna have to rerun the query to
get all team members so get team and
save and now we just need to hook up
this button so let's find that bottom
and on click we want to run a query and
that query is to delete team member
okay so there we go and shall we try it
out
let's do it I'm going to delete this
team member
and wonderful
so there we have it
and
I'm just going to re-add him luckily all
of this is still here as I have not
cleared that I've done that on purpose
just so it's easier for us for this
tutorial I'm just going to hit submit so
there's bow again
now for the email composer well it will
be quite nice to have whoever I'm
highlighting have their first name show
up so that's what I'm going to do I'm
going to once again use the tune table
selector of data to get the first name
of the person okay so there we go it
says hi bow so this is the default value
of our whole Rich Text Editor you can
put a comma that too and here as well we
can show who was sending this to so I
can use team table selector data email
this time
so great at the moment it's showing Bo
but if I select myself of course this
updates but this updates too and then I
can write an email and send it but of
course for that we need to hook this up
well I'm also going to do though is
whenever we send an email I'm going to
also send a text notification so that's
two resources we need to add let's go
ahead and do it so I'm going to go to
resources
and let's just hook up our twilio that
we signed up to before so please go
ahead and find twilio on here
that is twilia
and I'm going to do
Anya's
twilio
let's get the Sid account
so here is my account as ID
let's get the auth token
so here is my auth token I will be
deleting this so please don't think that
it will still work if you use it
I'm just going to select this as it's
not allowing me to update the IP
addresses and let's test the connection
so that connection is successful let's
create a resource wonderful so that is
now done I'm going to save these changes
and let's go back to resources and this
time I'm going to create another
resource this time it's going to be for
emailing I'm just going to scroll down
to a previous one that I've made and
reconfigure it so here are the settings
that you need however you do need to
have a Google workspace which is a paid
workspace for this to work now so my
Google workspace credentials are Anya at
codewithanya.com and then I'm just going
to put in my password for that email
okay so that's what you need to do let's
test the connection
and then we're just going to have to
allow less secure apps so just go to
your admin console and I'm just going to
search for a way to control access to
less secure apps okay so that's here we
go to settings and then we go to access
and data control and let's secure apps
and I'm going to allow users to manage
the less secure apps
great so that's for all users in my
company
and that connection is a success so
there we go we have done it great now
let's go back to our app just going to
get rid of that so now let's hook this
up I'm just going to create a new query
so let's create a new query resource
query this is going to be to send email
and this time the resource well it's
going to be Gmail
and the from email
is just going to be from Anya at
code
with
anya.com
and the two email is essentially going
to be whatever we are selecting right so
the selected row so let's go into the
team table selected row data email
where you can have a BBC or a cc I'm not
going to and this is just going to say
email from pager Duty clone
and the body well it's just going to be
the body of our Rich Text Editor so
we're going to go into Rich Text Editor
one and get the value
okay
great
and on success let's also just have some
confetti and save that and now let's
hook it up to the form button so event
handler on click we're going to control
the query send email because that is the
query that we are on now so let's pick
that up another thing I want to do is
actually just send a text message that
we got an email so this is going to be
another resource query send text and
this time this is going to be the
resource twilio that we just made so and
use twilia okay so that has been
pre-configured for me and this is the
operation we need to do it's a post
request this is the end point and it's
populated my account Sid that is good to
well who are we going to be sending this
to I'm going to put in my own phone
number in a bit to test this out but of
course usually you would go into the
team table selected or data and get the
phone number right so just like that so
let's go ahead and select someone so I
am selected so that should be bringing
up my phone number
the body I'm just going to put you have
an email notification from pager Duty
clone and from well from is going to be
my twilio phone number which is actually
in fact this you can get it from twilio
as well if you don't have it from here
please go ahead and add a parameter by
clicking here okay great so that's what
we want to do and let's just add some
confetti for when this
says and I'm just going to attach that
to this button too so send text trigger
okay so both those things will happen
now
because of course this number doesn't
really exist I am going to put in my
phone number so please look away
and let's say this and test it out
and great that has worked I should have
received State text
so let's check it out well first off I'm
just going to run this and see if that
has worked
and that's debug
okay
just make sure to have your email the
same one as you are using in the app and
that should work let's check the Gmail
account so I'm just going to sign in and
check out if I got an email and I did
okay here's my email of course it does
come as HTML so we're probably gonna
have to format that a little bit better
but at least it's sending something so
there we have it we have completed our
pager Duty app here is in all its Glory
it works the twilio API works the SMTP
API works we are using a postgres
database we can add incidents our team
members delete team members delete
incidents this is looking glorious I
hope this tutorial was useful and I hope
you had fun while learning and I'll see
you soon